[Music]
finding a job no matter your industry
can be tough and if you're hiring
getting your job in front of the right
candidate can be both challenging and
expensive part of the challenge is that
there is no standard for writing job
postings as companies we often use
internal language to describe job titles
that may not be obvious to job seekers
this issue is compounded by the fact
that most of the shelf search technology
is keyword based focusing on the two to
three generic words that often make up
job titles while keyword search is
effective at matching keywords to
content it typically fails to return
good results when used for job search
cloud job discovery offers access to
Google's proven search and machine
learning capabilities through a
plug-and-play cloud service improving
job discoverability job seeker
experience and conversion it's packed
with functionality such as seniority
alignment job related synonym and
acronym detection to improve the job
seeker experience and we're constantly
talking to job seekers to find
innovative ways to help them discover
new jobs like preferred commute time and
mode of transit so how does it work
let's take a look at a job site powered
by cloud job discovery this could be a
job board career site applicant tracking
system or any other jobs property the
job content on the site is first
inserted into a private tenant on the
Google cloud platform cloud job
discovery then goes to work
passing classifying and mapping the
content to pre-trained data models which
codify our knowledge and understanding
of occupations skills education and more
here's a visual representation of our
title data model which contains over 250
4000 normalized titles each belonging to
one of 30 top level categories this
knowledge enables us to return not just
the correct role for each job seeker but
also similar roles nearby
when jobseekers search on the site we
apply machine learning to truly
understand the intent of the query and
then retrieve rank and return highly
relevant results that continue to
improve over time hiring companies with
career sites powered by cloud job
discovery such as Johnson & Johnson has
seen remarkable increases in career site
engagement and candidate conversion
especially on hard to fill roles job
boards and applicant tracking systems
using cloud job discovery such as career
builder are also seeing increased
engagement and are benefiting from their
product and engineering teams ability to
focus on tasks higher in the tech stack
matching qualified candidates with the
right job doesn't have to be so hard let
Google power your job site with machine
learning and improve the discoverability
of jobs on your property learn more at
cloud.google.com
you